back on all fronts as Democrats push
forward in their impeachment inquiry
let's break it down for you
president Trump doubling down on his
calls to identify the whistleblower as
subpoenas have been issued for Rudy
Giuliani and Mike Pompeo the Secretary
of State
calling subpoenas and attempt to quote
bully and intimidate State Department
officials and last night Rudy took on
Biden watch this why do you think you're
silencing me because I'm not making any
points they're silencing me because I
showed up with an affidavit yesterday an
accuser who's willing to stand up and
point the finger at Joe Biden and say
you're a crook and I have the proof and
I have the documents and I've got the
witness we'll save the corroboration
because there are more witnesses where
he came from and they're not going to
escape this but the story Democrats
won't tell you about today is Joe Biden
caught lying about his knowledge of his
son's shady foreign business dealings
take a look at this newly unearthed
photo of Joe and hunter Biden playing
golf with a key Ukrainian gas executive
back in 2014 now remember when Joe went
ballistic and said he'd never spoken to
his son about those dealings I've never
spoke to my son about his overseas
business I know I know Trump deserves to
be investigated he is violating every
basic norm of a president you should be
asking him the question why is he on the
phone with a foreign leader trying to
intimidate a foreign leader all right
Dana it's been two weeks since the story
broke essentially about two weeks I was
like a year since Peter Doocy asked that
pointed question do you talk to your son
about his business dealings and we know
he lied when he said he doesn't and
remember he warned Peter you know don't
ask those types of questions and I think
the media has listened because the media
has not asked Joe Biden a direct
question about all of this and not only
that the guy at the epicenter of this
whole thing his son hunter where's
hunter they haven't found hunter
anywhere so it's interesting the
approaches so there was a piece today in
the Atlantic comparing
approach of dealing with impeachment to
president Trump's and the suggestion was
at Clinton handled it much better I just
don't think the two are quite comparable
especially because one of the things
Clinton had going for him was that the
media was helping you know basically not
trying to harm him
but the president's realizing is like
his allies are in the Republican Party
and that his approach has always been to
push and push and push the Biden
approach though and all of this has been
very it's curious to me I I don't know
it beyond seeing the picture I don't
know he says he didn't talk to his son
about it we haven't seen them we haven't
heard from them and but they are going
to have to testify when you play golf
with the foursome and one of the guys is
your son and the other guy's a mystery
guy who happens to have just been
appointed to the same gas company in
Ukraine that your son has been appointed
oh how do you guys know each other oh
we're on the same board just a month ago
this Ukrainian gas company and the
father Joe Biden is doing business in
Ukraine for the administration a
handicap I think because after all it is
golf and that's the only thing I know
about golf is handy but you know what
it's better than talking about this
which is the transcript which is the the
whistleblowers complaint Donald Trump
want us to talk about anything but this
and this is what has gotten him in hot
water is that the transcript or the
complaint no this is this is the version
that they want us to see look Joe Biden
work with the IMF to EU and others we
know what Joe Biden did we know that
there's been no evidence whatsoever of
corruption I went back Jesse because
because there's no evidence of no
because you inspired me
to read the entire 300 pages of
information out there and what I came up
with and I you know look I'm a very good
read I even put on my CVS purchase
glasses so I was really exact you get a
big receipt when you got this
yes and now $25 but so so here it is I
really do believe that the Trump
administration needs to treat Congress
as a co-equal branch of government I
think the administration needs to
cooperate with Congress and help them
get to the bottom of this so that this
saga will be over with by Thanksgiving
okay well one of the things
Jedidiah that they're trying to get to
the bottom of is the foreign
interference in the last election and
how this collusion hoax began in the
first place in bar has been directed to
talk to the Ukrainians to the Italians
to the British and to the Australians
and the media is panicking now there's
nothing wrong with that
there's once again there's nothing wrong
with that Lake I hate to say it but
there's nothing on the call I mean I
know I know they're saying old Pompeii
was on the call this is such breaking
news yeah well we were basically all on
the call to because the transcript is in
front of us all we know exactly what he
said and there's no quid pro quo there I
think Joe Biden's in trouble I think
he's in serious trouble this is a guy
who was doing a very bad job on the
debate stage he was underperforming to
say the least many people were getting
nervous you saw Elizabeth Warren rising
in the polls and now even though they
attempted to make this about Trump Joe
Biden and his dealings with his son and
what he did with respect to that
prosecutor that he wanted to get fired
and that taped that showed up of him
saying we're withholding money that all
implicates him in this and this is it's
not going to be long before many of
those donors who had Biden's back saying
he was the most electable are gonna pull
back and say you know what this guy has
too much baggage
he is implicated in this this does not
look good for him and even if you can't
stand President Trump you have to be
able to look at a call and say I don't
see any impeachable offense here be
realistic about it and say that Joe
Biden this was not all known to the
public by the way this there was reports
on it some people knew about this not
everybody knew about it this is not
gonna help him in 2020 but the reports
would fill a trash can and you don't
even have to let it on fire
look I'm not hit but he's on record
offensive name was Donna they were
saying that they had a problem with
potential quid pro quo when it came to
President Joe Biden is on record saying
oh you're not gonna get the money
boasting about it unless well he said
that is him speaking in his own water I
recognize that the senator also has
subpoena power and if you
drag him before the committee of course
I don't speak with the authority of God
okay but Greg Joe Biden is gonna have to
report his fundraising numbers very soon
and the president and his committee just
came out with a whopping 125 million
dollar third-quarter Hall yeah what do
you make of that I think that's a lot of
money Jesse a lot of crimes look I'm
focusing on what the media is doing
right now and what they are doing is
shaping public opinion all right so
let's say a week and a half ago nobody
cared about impeachment the number said
they didn't want an impeachment it was a
bad idea 2mph would be bad for the
country those numbers have shifted too
dramatically which is the media
reporting that it's shifting
dramatically so who's been pushing those
buttons and pulling those strings the
same media reporting this the story
hasn't changed at all so it's not about
reporting it's about repetition the
story is so small but what's even
smaller is the people that are
generating it I have a theory that a
thousand people are generating this
story right it's the if that it might be
but 500 people are dictating the what
330 350 million people are listening to
right now this is a splash fight in the
tiniest kiddie pool of influencers and
it's a self-perpetuating media machine
that must generate louder and louder
noise as we realize how little there is
there is no there there and I'll even go
that way with byte I'll say there's no
there there period but this story itself
is so small and the people that are
generating this sound is so small I mean
we're being sold a bill of goods
remember the good old days when scandals
were scandalous yeah I mean Watergate
iran-contra Monica gate this is scandal
impersonation I'm insulted that I'm
wasting my time listening to this crap
it's like it's like when you at night
when you were a kid and you woke up in
the middle of the night you thought
there was a monster in your room but it
was just clothes on a chair this is
clothes on a chick it was
bodies break-ins and sex I think this is
good to your last point about the money
yeah
this helps Trump because it angers the
public because they feel that they're
being drawn into a false drama including
even the Biden stuff you have a
fist-sized group of people having a
monumental effect on an entire country
and they're just say it screw you I'm
voting for the mo for that I'm voting
for the orange devil whether you like it
or not all right
Wow Gregg is on fire